For the reserve parachute we mostly use single Aramid fibres,
which are thicker and woven much less densely.
The important thing about that, as mentioned before, is that when the canopy opens
you don't get a huge shock load — the whole system,
the seam stays intact, the canopy keeps its shape, stays dimensionally stable lengthwise.
Those are the desirable properties.
There are several different reserve-parachute designs. As you can see here, in the middle
we have the so-called cross-cell reserve — that's pretty much the current market standard and works very well.
The red one on the lower left is an older model — a round canopy,
which is being displaced by the cross design for one simple reason:
the cross reserve is very pendulum-stable, while round canopies tend to swing.
There are also other shapes — this one here is a triangular reserve,
which can build forward speed and be steered. These are reserved for more advanced pilots,
because after pulling the reserve you have to actively steer it.
For a student or a recreational pilot, the cross-cell reserve makes a lot of sense — it's pendulum-stable.
Everything is fine and you don't need to focus on a separate steering system.
When you deploy a reserve parachute,
you come down at roughly 5.5 metres per second, which corresponds
— as you saw on the image — to jumping from about 1.5 metres.
But for a 1.5-metre jump you're not carrying anything,
whereas here we have the whole paraglider, the harness,
the helmet, etc.
That's already quite a bit of extra weight.
And then 1.5 metres can get tricky.
There's a small impact on the ground when you land like that.
In reality it tends to feel more like jumping from 2 to 3 metres.
Reserve parachutes are certified by dropping them from a helicopter or from a bridge,
but always without the paraglider attached.
So the weight is there, but the wing isn't tagged along.
That's not how it works in real life.
In reality the paraglider is usually still connected to us.
The wing can interfere a bit.
That means the whole system tends to swing a little.
It definitely influences the descent rate, which can be noticeably higher.
That said, even at 4 m/s
it's an impact you can absorb reasonably well.
Most importantly, get onto your feet —
don't just sit down,
and don't try to land on the harness protector.
The protector is never as good as we'd like.
There's no better cushion, so the absolute priority after pulling the reserve
is to land on your feet.
Speaking of protectors — there are very different harness types,
each with different protector designs.
On the left we have a classic foam protector.
The advantage is that the protection is there from the start,
but the big downside is the weight.
And when you pack it, it stays pretty bulky.
There are other designs that aim to
reduce volume in flight.
They use airbag protectors,
which only fill once you're airborne,
when airflow forces air into them.
At launch — exactly when it matters most — you have no protection.
There are also other forms…
There are designs
such as harnesses
with the harness integrated directly into the backpack.
Those are convertible harnesses.
The convertible harness has the advantage of not needing a separate backpack,
which saves weight.
But every year we now have to deal with the zips,
and the zips take a lot of wear,
so there's more potential for damage.
And the protector ends up packed
fairly compressed,
and after multiple uses it no longer unfolds as nicely
as it should.
To solve all of this,
one manufacturer developed a very good system
which we see in the right-hand image —
a harness
whose protector is inflated before flight,
either by hand or with an inflation bag,
so the air is inside,
we close it up, and from the moment we launch
we already have great protection.
And if you don't need it,
you simply let the air out —
tiny volume and very little weight.
There's also an extreme variant
people choose, for example for hike-and-fly,
where they skip protection entirely.
We can see it on the left —
just a strap-style sling,
a minimal harness you can sit in comfortably,
but with no protection.
And the reserve has to be mounted separately
rather than integrated inside the harness.
Among the other designs, there's the lying (prone) harness.
There's now a beginner-suited variant too,
but it loses some of its strengths.
Ultimately the big advantages
of a prone harness are clear:
you fly through the air more dynamically,
and you get a better glide performance from the wing.
You're also well shielded from the wind,
which keeps you warm on long flights,
and you have plenty of space for a cockpit.
There's even a small instrument shelf
where you can mount a device perfectly
with a clear view of the screen.
Anyone who flies competitions
or long XC flights,
spending several hours in the air,
tends to have their own prone harness,
and they really value those advantages.
The downside is the more awkward way you have to climb in,
since you're not fully upright.
It's a very different feeling.
You have to learn it.
And we don't have a direct view upward,
which is why, for school,
a sitting harness makes total sense.
And then there are several other clear classes:
hike-and-fly harnesses,
tandem harnesses,
acro and freestyle pods,
and other purpose-built harnesses.
Right now there are many different and good harnesses on the market.
Here too, it's worth
trying things on,
sitting in them,
to find the one that fits you.
The construction of a paraglider
is, in the end,
shown here in a simplified form.
We have the risers.
You can see here
where we're attached to the harness.
Then the brake loops,
which are connected,
and there's a small remark about them:
when we have brake loops,
we hold them like this,
wrap them once around the hand,
but do not put the hand through and fly like that.
Because if the hand were inside the loop
and you had to pull the reserve,
especially in winter
when we have gloves on,
you'd struggle to get your hand out.
So the technique is
to keep the hand free at all times.
Then we have the small
brake lines
attached to the trailing edge of the wing.
Then we have the A, B and other riser groups.
The A-riser group is the front group,
the leading edge,
where the air enters.
And then it flows over the bottom surface.
And inside the paraglider
we have a lot of internal structure:
cells separated by walls,
and the so-called crossports.
Crossports are just holes.
The cell walls cause
the air to distribute evenly across the wing.
As we've seen before with a paraglider,
we have openings at the front,
and at the outside, toward the stabilo,
the edge of the wing,
the openings are closed.
And that's where the air, at the wingtip,
creates a super-rigid pressure
so the wing lies beautifully in the air.
And when it's open,
we have crossports
that let air flow between cells.
On the risers themselves,
as we've seen,
we have the riser levels,
small connectors,
small screw-link carabiners,
and we have the accelerator (speed system).
Here we see a foot accelerator,
which we attach
by clipping into the first stirrup,
connecting it to the harness,
and pressing it with the foot.
That does nothing other than
pulling the A-riser group down at the top,
and what happens then:
the angle of attack decreases,
and the wing flies faster.
The foot accelerator,
as we see in this picture,
is fitted to solo wings
because there pilots can comfortably
use leg extension and full load
to add speed,
while on a tandem
that works less well.
On a tandem,
with the tandem wing,
we have trimmers,
as you can see here,
that can be pulled out and let back,
as we've discussed,
and you can do that beautifully
with your hands,
without needing your feet —
because at the front,
with the passenger,
there's no space.
The advantage of the trimmer
is naturally that
you can use it by hand,
and you can see it clearly.
But it doesn't release as quickly afterwards.
You have to actively pull it back with your hand.
With the foot accelerator you simply press
and release.
It's easy to operate.
Trimmer — don't confuse it
with the trim setting,
which is set on the line,
and which you can adjust.
Now we move on —
since we're already on line material:
we have various lines,
they shrink a little,
the line layers.
And the manufacturer tries
to prevent that as much as possible
by mixing different line types
appropriately.
Still,
it happens
that lines deform,
either getting longer or shorter,
and we only notice this during a check.
If you then find
that the lines have indeed
lengthened,
you can — for example — loop them
and re-tie them.
(diagram / numbers shown on slide)
(slide reference)
The lines are packed neatly inside the stuff sack, so they get as little sun exposure as possible — sun degrades the lines
so they're only exposed when actually flying.
Next general topic.
On the lines: it's not good when they get really wet — they shrink,
if the fibres get soaked.
And the wing being wet isn't a problem in itself, as long as you talk about it right away.
What's bad is when a wet wing then sits in a backpack,
and the backpack is left for two or three weeks — that's definitely not good for the material.
Crucially, if you have a wet wing, dry it — lay it out flat,
and only pack it again once it's fully dry.
The very worst thing you can do is have a wet wing and then expose it to high temperatures.
The classic example is leaving it in a car in summer — quickly over 30 or 40 °C inside.
It turns into a little oven, and that's really bad for the material.
So make sure the material is dry and not exposed to extreme temperatures.
Acid is another thing — if a battery starts to leak you might get an acidic stain,
and that, too, attacks the wing's coating.
What's also important is that when you need to clean it, you use lukewarm water — never with cleaning agents,
because those will attack the coating.
And since we're on coatings, that's a good keyword.
The paraglider has a coating so that the cloth doesn't react with UV light, and more importantly so that
it doesn't leak too much air through porosity. If a wing leaks too much air, the glide performance drops,
leak performance increases — and we want to prevent that with this coating.
The coating, the ripstop weave — it varies in thickness, because the threads vary in thickness.
The coating is applied over the top, and it's designed so that
the thickness variations get evened out, giving a uniform thickness across the cloth, so the wing's behaviour stays predictable,
air permeability stays good, and overall the wing reacts less abruptly.
I hope you enjoyed the equipment talk — see you again in the next lesson, and good luck with the equipment chapter on the briefing.